once you've learned how to parse JSON
data it's pretty straightforward to be
able to parse the rest of the fields
that we need since this isn't a course
on Java or JSON we're going to provide
you with the parsing code in the gist
below and this is what the gist looks
like there are three helper methods the
first is for formatting dates the second
is for rounding temperatures the third
is returning a forecast JSON string into
an array of weather forecasts update the
fetchweathertask to use these helper
functions and the do and background
method should return a string array of
forecasts you can log the output to
check that the array is correct the
format of one days forecast should look
like this